money is rarely the greatest loss
there's relationships that were ruined
it ruined my career it Stripped Away all
of my life prospects James is one of
thousands across the country who have
battled a gambling addiction these
stacks of paper are his losses to just
one company during a 12-year addiction
that started when he was just 16.
campaigners and recovering addicts like
him are demanding tougher regulation and
fast there's too much Reliance on
individuals with a mental health
condition an addiction to stop gambling
and that's naive actually there needs to
be much better regulation that means the
gambling companies aren't encouraging
people to gamble more than they can
afford to or incentivize in what is
essentially an illness rules do exist
but they are routinely flouted in the
latest case William Hill was fined a
record 19.2 million pounds for allowing
customers to bet thousands of pounds
without any checks and weak anti-money
laundering controls a brand new customer
near account opened lost 23 000 pounds
in 20 minutes another loss just under
fifteen thousand pounds in 70 minutes
another 32 000 pounds in two days that
sort of thing is unacceptable
in the last year alone more than 76
million pounds was paid out because of
regulatory failures
it's clear that the system isn't working
but while gambling companies continue to
make bumper profits campaigners and
bereaved families are still waiting for
a long promised overhaul of the
country's betting laws
Britain has the world's largest
regulated online gambling industry
a white paper outlining new laws was
promised in December 2020 but it has
been repeatedly delayed
when published it's expected to include
a ban on so-called VIP packages on
betting sites tighter Financial controls
and a levy on gambling companies to help
fund treatment and awareness programs we
need to have a much more aggressive
position from the commission which is
based very clearly on what they are
failing to do and the Damage that it
causes to lives so the white paper will
deal with that it's been 18 years since
this country's gambling laws were
updated for people like James tougher
regulation couldn't come soon enough
Sky News